BAS ROOKHUIJZEN:
Thank you very much,
and welcome in
break room number 3,
in how you are going
to learn from us what
the power of the
cloud is based on,
a little introduction
of myself, but more
important the real customer
story of Ruben Kruit,
CTO of Young Capital.
Thank you very much for
joining us today, Ruben Kruit.
So I am going to start
introducing to you
why the cloud has been
so important to Google
to achieving our goals,
and how we have applied it
in our day-to-day technology,
and how we collaborate
in order for other companies
to have advantages of that
as well.
My name is Bas Rookhuijzen.
I'm account executive
at Google Cloud.
And I'm here today to help you
with any questions regarding
these topics.
So what we want to achieve
with this cloud product
and what we're going
to elaborate on today
is we want to
bring teams closer,
so that you can move faster and
go bigger than the competition.
Actually what most
of the speakers
already confirmed at the
key note this morning,
Bill Hippenmeyer
elaborated on that.
But what's more
important than that alone
is why is that so
important right now.
Why was the technology that
we used 5 or 10 years ago
sufficient enough to
stay ahead of the curve
and to communicate with each
other the way we were used to?
Why is that no longer
sufficient enough?
Why do we need to amend
faster than we should?
Because one reason, disruptive
technology-driven startups
are taking over the world.
They're becoming more and
more relevant every day.
And they become more
and more powerful.
So we have to act like
disruptive technology-driven
startups to stay
ahead of the curve.
We have been doing so
over the last 17 years.
And we want to help
and inspire you,
hopefully that you can
cherry pick from our ideas
and move at the same pace.
Culture is more important
even then technology alone.
What we have learned
from startups
and from our own organization,
is that three things
are very important to remember.
First of all, we need a very
strong mission statement,
how to organize the
world's information
and how to make it universally
accessible and useful.
That's the mission
statement of Google,
regardless where you work at
the self-driving car department,
if you work at YouTube
or at Google Cloud.
Everybody wants to organize
the world's information.
That's our motivation.
And we're looking for
people, partners, employees,
colleagues that want to
contribute to the same goal
as well.
So that's our primary statement.
And every company has its own
very relevant mission statement
to focus on.
Secondly, transparency
helps us to move quickly.
Open information,
everything is open.
Everybody can access
information very fast.
It's pivotal for
innovation processes.
In order to innovate
with the same speed
as disruptive
technology-driven startups,
you need to have a very open and
transparent culture and a very
open and transparent
technology platform.
That's why transparency
is so important.
And thirdly, voice
is very important.
So everybody in the
organization has the same power
to create an initiative,
to create products,
to create a new project.
And an example that I can give
you today is based on this URL,
I would ask you to use if you
have questions for me today.
This is a very
simple tool to use.
You simply type in the URL.
You'll access a site.
You can ask a question.
You'll see each
other's questions.
And Ruben and myself will
answer the top three questions.
Because you can like
each other's questions.
And the question that
has most likes we
are committed to answer at
the end of this presentation.
So that's something
that we use as well.
Google has 60,000-70,000
employees in the meantime.
We have a TGIF every week.
You know, TGIF, right?
It's thank Google it's Friday.
And on this Friday, we have a
presentation of Diane Greene,
our CEO; or Sundar,
or the group's CEO
presenting to us our new
strategy or new products,
financial numbers, and
thousands of people
are watching that live stream.
We were used to sending
questions to those speakers
afterwards, or sending
it to the secretary.
And well, the representation
of the best question
being answered on stage
wasn't always quite fair.
So the question answered
was for the best interest
of the speaker in most times.
So we designed this specific
tool for ourselves as well.
We created the website.
And colleagues can
like those questions.
We think it's a
very democratic way
to get the best questions
rising to the top.
Because the best idea
can come from anywhere.
And that's the key
message that we
want to send in this
organization is the best
idea can come from
anywhere, can come
from the vice president
in your organization,
executive vice president.
It can come from some high
potential during a workshop.
Or most likely it can
come from somebody
who's in direct contact
with your customer,
feels the friction, and can
solve something right away.
You want to give somebody that
power and the speed of movement
there right away.
Well, this is what
enables the cloud.
We have data centers
all over the world.
We invest about $10 billion
per year in those data centers.
Realizing this network,
with our own glass fiber
network crossing the planet.
So we're the only company in
the world that has its own glass
fiber network across
the planet that
will give the
customers and the users
optimal performance of the apps
that you deploy on our network,
and also the apps that
you use, regardless
of whether you're in Tokyo,
or in Iowa, or in London,
or wherever in the
world you're going
to have a very short latency
towards the information.
Because we ship the information
with you wherever you go.
And that helps you to get
a top-notch performance
with cloud performance.
That's very important.
So what is going wrong at
traditional companies today?
Why are companies like
Kodak, Blockbuster,
and numerous other
companies going down
based on competition from
disruptive technology-driven
startups?
It's all about culture.
Firstly, they see information
as being top secret.
It's very difficult to access
certain points of information.
You need to ask for permission.
You need a certain
clearance level.
You need a lot of
time and effort
spent to get to the
right information.
And that's a disaster for your
innovation pace, of course.
So your people in
your organization
who are in direct contact
with your customers,
if they take a lot
of time to figure out
what the right and
relevant information is,
then you're already too
late in this world today.
So you're too slow.
Secondly what we see
is that making mistakes
is being perceived at
traditional companies
as being very, very expensive.
So complete careers are
built upon, in fact,
making as few
mistakes as possible.
So we think it's very
important that there
is a culture of
psychological safety.
That people are not
afraid of making mistakes,
because in this digital
day and age making
mistakes should
not be expensive.
And finally it's what
we call the fat cat.
And the fat cat represents
the decision making power
lies in the hands of the few.
In traditional companies
there are only a few people
in the organization that
have the power to say yes
to a certain initiative.
And that's bad for two reasons.
Number one, it takes a lot
of time to get on the agenda.
Every Tuesday morning there's
a qualification analysis,
or a spend board,
or a review board.
And secondly, it's a
disaster because people
blow their project
out of proportion.
Perhaps they only need $5,000.
But they suddenly project their
project to be worth tenfold
or a hundredfold in order to get
on the agenda of this fat cat,
as we call it.
And that's also a disaster
for your innovation process.
So what does work?
We would like to share with you.
First of all, those disruptive
technology-driven organizations
focus on all the data is online.
Everything is in the cloud.
You can access it everywhere.
That's the nature of disruptive
technology-driven startups.
They do not invest in
on-premise hardware,
do not invest in highly
specialized technology people
for the infrastructure part.
They rely on the information
that's available in the cloud.
Secondly, they build everything
primarily for mobile.
Because mobile is
the primary user
interface of all your
users, all your consumers.
Therefore, also
more relevant if you
build any app on
that platform, it's
going to need to
be mobile first,
especially because the
mobile phone doesn't
rely on the CPU alone
of the mobile phone.
It primarily relies on the big
data centers, the Google Cloud
Platform, for instance.
Who of you has ever used
an Uber app, for instance?
Most of you, right?
The Uber app doesn't rely on
the CPU power of your phone.
It relies on the CPU power
of the cloud calculating
where the nearest cab
driver is, of course.
And the possibilities
are limitless because
of this vast technology.
So there are limitations
is in your own creativity.
And the moment that you
block that creativity,
then you'll be slower
than the competition.
And that's a disaster.
We've seen it at Uber.
We've seen it at Kodak.
We've seen it a Blockbuster,
a mix of companies
that have affected the world.
And it's going
faster and faster.
And I like this slide a lot.
It's the CB Insights slides.
It's the Unicorn Club.
You're part of the
Unicorn Club if you're
worth over a billion dollars.
And what CB Insights
did, they said
that they projected this
on a time scale going back,
dating back way
further than this.
But I focused on this part.
Especially because
what you can see
is that the founding date is
projected on this timeline
here.
And it's getting
increasingly crowded today,
mainly because of the fact
that it takes less time
to found a company that's
worth a billion dollars.
And that supports the
statement of that the fact that
disruptive technology-driven
startups are very relevant.
And that's our next
competition, regardless
of what segments you are.
It's going faster and faster
because of Moore's law.
And Moore's law, I don't
need to explain to you.
But it's every 18 months
the CPU quality doubles,
and the price halves, right?
So it's 50% every 18 months.
And it has been like
that since the invention
of the personal computer by IBM.
And every year people say, OK,
it's not going to continue.
It's impossible.
It still happens.
So that's why they keep--
because technology expressed
is so, so incredibly strong.
So what we did at Google is
we translated our learning
over the last 17 years into
a couple of investment themes
that we have to be
aware of at the moment
that we are going to
be more productive.
First of all, we need
to focus on the teams.
That's the most important
part, the culture part.
We want to make a
tool set that allows
them to work real time to give
them the feeling that they're
working in small teams
together to foster
these serendipitous
connections, as we call it.
That's the source of innovation.
Secondly, it needs
to be super secure.
People need to get the
feeling that wherever
they work, on what device.
There is no risk of
information getting leaked.
Because that's a hygiene
factor number one.
Thirdly, it's
beyond productivity.
That means that
we're going to help
you do more with less time.
And of course because we really
believe in the best idea can
come from anywhere, we
want to create a platform
where customers and
partners can build upon.
So that you can add
quality to the database.
We see that more apps
are built on our network
than we build ourselves.
So the platform
is very important,
and usability is pivotal.
And that's something that
Ruben will elaborate on
as well that if you want
to be able to apply it,
the adoption rate
needs to be high
and the usability
needs to be easy.
We call it a toothbrush rule.
We optimize for growth,
not for revenue.
And a toothbrush
rule means if you
develop something
that doesn't require
a manual for a billion people to
use they don't need to download
the manual first or
look at a YouTube movie
or enroll for training, then
the product is a success.
That's for us, the
toothbrush rule.
And that's why usability
is so important.
These are the products
today that we have developed
based on this principle.
It's not written in a vacuum.
But these are the
products today that you
can use that we embedded this
knowledge of our culture in.
This is what we
specifically needed
when we started to
build Google.com, when
we saw that the tools
that we had to communicate
were not sufficient enough,
were enough fast enough.
They were too expensive and
required too much backbone
technologists to run on.
And that's why we
developed our own G Suite.
And that's what we have brought
to the enterprise market
as well.
Teams is for us the
most important part.
That's why I mentioned
it a couple of times.
We want to work
teams in small teams.
We have calculated, we have
estimated at the moment
that you work 3 meters apart
is going to be exponential
higher productivity than when
you work 18 meters apart,
let alone when you
work from home.
So that's why we want
everybody, by default,
to work in the office together.
That's not always
possible, because people
work across the globe.
That's why we created products
with high-resolution images
like Hangout, to ensure people
to be able to work together,
as if they were working
next to each other.
Hangout chat is a
product of that,
that you have seen today as
well, where people can very
easily exchange information
and Hangout Meet
is a video conference service
embedded in your agenda,
embedded in the meeting
rooms, where you immediately
can include meeting
rooms, book meeting rooms,
and have the feeling that you're
together, even though there
is an ocean in between you.
Team Drives is something that
we have introduced recently
that I encourage
you to check what's
possible with Team Drives.
Team Drives a folder
environment where
you're able to share
information with each other,
beyond your own ownership.
So in the past we
had a dry folder.
And you were the owner.
And the moment that
you left the company,
the documents were only to be
accessed by the administrator,
for instance.
Now we have Team
Drives that allows
you to use Drive as you
would have used fileshare,
for instance.
There is one folder
at the f drive,
and everybody can find
it, and it's easy.
Live updates on what
we do on Google sites,
so it's very easy to
create internet sites,
and update it all the time.
And it's obviously very secure,
built on our own security
levels, like you have heard
this morning of Julien.
So we have seven-- and
I heard this morning,
eight even products with
1 billion users each.
So we have to be very secure.
so that's a hygiene
factor of us.
We have many, many
questions that we get.
Are you secure enough?
Because it's in
the cloud and it's
spread out all
over the world, how
do I know all my data is safe?
We're more than happy to go
in a conversation with you
in detail.
But it's built up
because we have
our own proprietary hardware
we build around data centers.
We have our own
glass fiber cables.
We have control of
any aspect in the IT.
And that why it's so super safe.
What we specifically
to want to focus on
is phishing, for instance.
That's what CIOs worry
about, mobile management data
breaches, or personal part.
So CIOs usually believe that
we have the back end covered.
But the front end is
more of a problem.
How do you get your users safe?
And that's why we
have this program
to help users to be more
secure, automatically,
but for instance a security key.
So you don't need
an OTP code anymore.
It's simply something
that you have,
something that you know
embedded in one device.
And then you're free to go.
Mobile device management
is very important.
We've deployed that recently
with the entire Dutch National
Police Force.
We are doing the mobile
device management for them.
They haven't had a
security breach since then.
So we're very happy to
have them as a partner,
as a reference for the future.
Where we can help them
audit and edit the data
based on a configuration basis.
And they no longer need
to technically update it
all the time.
First-party apps
are part of that,
and there is a platform
where everybody can built on.
As a third party, you can
easily with API integration,
build your platforms
on top of that.
With the Gmail
add-ons for instance,
you can integrate
it with other apps.
And that might be very
useful for your environment.
Productivity is pivotal
for getting the most out
of your employees.
We apply machine
learning to that
to increase the productivity.
We help you with smart replies.
We help you with setting a
reply already ready there
at the moment that you
receive an email that you only
need to press OK and
the mail is gone.
And it saves you a lot of time.
Find the time and calendar
is also an example that we
are going to improve over time.
It's already there, and there is
an interoperability possibility
with the Microsoft
environment as well.
It's going to be very
short presentation
that I want to show you.
Bill Hippenmeyer
showed you this morning
a presentation
about spreadsheets.
But he didn't give a demo
on how it actually works.
And that's why I
quickly set up a row.
Can we have that on screen?
So these are a couple
of rows and columns
based on sales information.
And like Bill Hippenmeyer,
I'm not a hero in coding.
I'm not a hero in
spreadsheet management.
So they simply designed
this button here.
I go to explore, and
I ask a question.
For instance, what is the
average cost of goods?
And it starts calculating,
and without any reference
it says 48.66.
So it's already-- so it
takes out the context
and it immediately helps me
analyze big chunks of data
without me being an expert.
Can we go back to
the presentation?
And that helps.
It allows you to be
productive throughout the day.
We don't need special
trainings for that.
I advise you to
visit the Jamboard.
There's a Jamboard available
to you to play around with.
This is actually a white
board that's usually used.
But then it's interactive.
So you can use it
across the planet.
There's another Jamboard.
And you can draw things
up live at a stake.
Last example that
I want to give you
is our search abilities
that we have implemented
in our products at first.
So the moment that
you use Google,
we enable you to search
through all the documents
like you are used to
from Google, right?
So it's optimal
character recognition.
You are able to find the
documents much faster than you
were used to.
In seconds you'll have all
the relevant information.
Not just that, we're going to
base it on the context base,
on the device you're using based
on your next calendar entry
we're going to deliver
you the documents that
are relevant for you, right.
So the moment that you
have a calendar entry which
your colleague is going to
get all the documents that you
recently shared with
that specific colleague,
it's going to present
it to you immediately.
And that's going to
save you a lot of time,
and get you a lot of more
value out of your work.
And that's called
Google Cloud Search.
So it's going to improve
your productivity massively.
And this is the last one I want
to share with you on the Drive,
share file.
What it does, it actually
synchronizes all the files
that you have on your local
machine up in the cloud
without you having to
worry about your folder
or file structure
that you're used to.
So it helps the
usability massively.
Because you do not really need
to explain a lot in what's
new in the other environment.
For people who are not used to
work with Gmail, for instance.
These are the roadmap
implementations
that we promised to do
the coming quarters.
The reason why I show this is
that Google is being perceived
as a consumer product.
Since last year, we have
turned into an enterprise
ready company.
We're focusing on
enterprises mainly.
And that means that we have
to be more predictable.
We used to deprecate
an application
when we didn't see enough
traction in the consumer world.
And the enterprise
partners of ours
who were used to
working with that
suddenly saw this
application disappear,
and they were in trouble.
So that's what we have changed.
We promised that those
applications will be there,
and you are able to
anticipate on what's coming
and what's next to help you
to run your organization more
professionally and
what you expect
from a professional
enterprise company.
So without further ado,
I would like to thank you
for listening to my story.
Without further
ado, I would like
to present to you Ruben
Kruit, CTO of Young Capital.
And he is going
to elaborate on--
OK, beautiful words boss,
but how does it actually
work at a real company?
Young Capital,
thank you very much.
RUBEN KRUIT: All right.
Thank you, Bas.
[APPLAUSE]
Bas, you mentioned Young Capital
as being a respected customer.
Well, I would like
to convert back
to say that Google is a very
highly respected supplier
for us, not to just
compliment you,
but I'll get back on it
later in the presentation.
That's a very important factor.
So I'm going to tell you
more about the transition
that we did to G Suite.
A little more about
Young Capital,
you might have heard of us.
Because we're pretty active
campaigning last year.
We're basically an
employment agency
who exists for 15
years, found our place
in the online channels
to mainly focus on--
well, the Young Capital of the
Netherlands, find them a job.
So we work now over with
around about 900 employees
on 41 locations.
We're a pretty young company.
Average age of our
population is 25 years old,
meaning the staff
that works with us.
And we have some serious issue.
We have a growth
of 63% last year.
And we're doing the same
thing this year again.
So that's a serious--
that's a serious challenge.
So therefore, we as
the IT department
have some challenges too.
So we need to find a way to
make this company future-proof,
meaning we want to
work completely online.
That makes this flexible,
makes us anticipate quickly
to market changes.
Because there's a
young population
that we're aiming for.
It also means there's
a lot of changes
along the way next
to external factors.
So we went into
this finding a way
to integrate with
our applications.
First of all, finding a partner
that fits your IT landscape,
but maybe more important-- and
that's why I compliment you--
is finding a company that
really fits your DNA, meaning
that we're aiming
for a partner where
we can conquer the world with.
So they already did.
And we're hard on our
way to do the same thing.
Therefore, I want to focus
on not the technical aspects
of this transition.
If you want to know more about
that, our key figures of the IT
department who did
the technical impact
analysis and the
transition and migration,
you can get in contact
with them later on.
But this is more about
change management.
Because you're
changing the tools,
the tool kit of
your people, where
they work on a daily basis.
So that's high impact.
That means you're changing the
way they work on a daily basis.
First of all, because
it's about change
management, my first
phase is hire an expert.
So you've never
done this before.
And because it's so high
impact, therefore we
hired a company who had
a lot of best practices
from other companies.
And they really did
a great job for us.
So that's the first thing
I want to advise on.
This is the way we did it.
Well, it seems obvious.
One thing I want to really
focus on is the first part.
What's in it for me?
Because that's really
important, meaning what's
in it for the company.
Well, you do the
number crunching.
You do your business case.
You do the technical analysis.
But this is something you
can decide with your board.
But this is about changing
the tool set of people working
with it on a daily basis.
So therefore, what's in it for
me is a very important thing,
not from top to bottom
but from bottom to top.
So what we did, we went
to the worker floor.
And detected a
number of use cases
where people were finding real
constraints in their processes.
And we detected them,
and we made sure
that it became feasible
for the whole company.
So here's a video
of several use cases
where we find real constraints.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- At home I use Gmail.
- What program do
you use at home?
- Gmail.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[END PLAYBACK]
Well, that was some side catch.
Yeah, the fun part
is, of course,
that once you go
into your company,
you ask what the people
do in the real work,
then you come up with
all kinds of things
that people are really dealing
with, and find some bypasses.
But also you experience
that they're already
using in their private lives,
a lot of tools Google already
provided.
So what's in it for me led do
some use cases that we found,
some constraints that we found.
That were not on the
business case yet,
but were serious, serious
gains for the company,
not only for the company, but
for the people doing the work.
So it's improving not only
the results for your company.
It's improving the life
of your employees as well.
So here are a
variety of use cases.
And I want to take
one out of here,
which is pretty significant.
So it's starting up your
computer for instance.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
Well, I expect everybody in the
room to be pretty tech savvy.
But for how many people was
this a recognizable situation?
I think for a lot of people,
and it saves a lot of time.
And it improves also
the fun of working.
So this was basically
from all the use cases,
the roundup of the results.
So how do we do it?
I will pick some aspects
out of a process we used.
So first of all,
training your staff
is pretty important,
knowing what to do.
Set good guidelines.
Do some proper planning.
Take your time for it.
Another-- well, I think
the most crucial factor
was our Google heroes.
So there we didn't
select people.
We just asked for who
wants to voluntarily apply
for becoming a Google hero.
And that's a pretty
important factor.
That means people
are intrinsically
motivated to be an ambassador
of this new product.
So from on the work
floor, you have
your peers who are promoting
a new way of working,
a new tool set, which is
I think a crucial factor
in the success of having
a successful change.
Additionally, give
a lot of attention
to special user groups.
There are some maybe Excel
wizards within your company,
maybe in your
financial department.
The PAs, for instance, who are
doing the calendar, so a few
of the board.
They are so used
to their tools that
make sure that you give
them special attention
and show them maybe
a new way of working.
Help them finding a
new way of working.
Another thing is it's not only
about a technical transition.
It's also a moment of fun.
Because you're changing
the way of working.
But it's also a
momentum that you
can take to see, well, we're
going to do it differently.
But we're going to do
it in a very nice way.
So therefore, the project
team plants the seeds.
The Google heroes make it work.
That's really important.
But also another major
aspect is that you endorse it
as management.
So this is a decision
that we made.
We're going to do it.
There's no way back.
We're going to
really make it work.
And again, make it work
in a way that people also
know that it's going
to be a fun project.
Not my best picture, so if
you have rats in your basement
and you want to get rid of
them, I can email it to you.
But this is how we
approach it from the board,
to really make sure we're
going to go into Google.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PHONE RINGING]
- Google.
Google.
[PHONE RINGING]
- Google.
Google.
OMG!
[PHONE RINGING]
- Google.
[NON-ENGLISH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- [NON-ENGLISH]
How sweet is that?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
Yeah, well that emphasizes
that really it's
bringing new energy
into your company.
And you really
need to show that,
from the top to the bottom,
from the bottom to the top.
So is it all good?
Is it all a success story?
No, there are a lot of practical
things that you walk into.
So for instance,
these are the things
that came up within our
channels that the Google
heroes had to face.
So that there are logical things
that people ask themselves,
and some practical
things as well.
So about your email
signature, it was really
an issue within our company.
So it's an important thing.
Because we send a lot of emails
to a lot of people every day.
So it's like a
marketing tool for us.
It's pretty important that it
works the way it should be.
We cannot use the phone
that we bought online.
So, how do you deal
with those things?
Pretty important matters,
but you have to face them.
Again, the Google heroes
are crucial in this.
Because in an informal
way, they help everybody
to overcome all these
practical issues.
So where do we stand now?
I emphasized in the beginning
of the presentation,
take your time.
Because this is serious.
It's not a matter of rushing.
Therefore, I think you should
take about 3-4 months at least
to make sure that you go into
kind of a change management
process, not only doing
your technical things.
But make sure marketing
communications is involved.
And you set up the
right channels.
Make sure that
you take your time
to find your Google
heroes, and make it happen.
So, how did it go?
We're not there yet.
But we're quite a long
way in the process.
Well, there were
technical issues.
But strangely enough, about
4% of our mailboxes we had
issues with.
And once we did migration,
the first work day,
we already solved those issues.
Again, the special
interest groups, we really
had to focus on them.
Because we found out
that some of them had
matters that we didn't foresee.
A good side catch
in this part was us
that we also found
some processes that
didn't fit the logic of Google.
Basically those process sucked.
So we had to change
that as well.
So that's a good
side catch from going
into these kind of transitions.
So to sum it all up, what
are the crucial factors?
See this process as a
change management project,
and make sure that you get
people who can seriously
take time for doing the change.
Make it phased,
and take your time.
Because it's a serious process.
The board, they really need
to endorse this program.
Because if they see doubt
within the people that
manage the company, then the
people who are doing the work
will be doubtful too.
As mentioned numerous times
within this presentation,
the Google heroes.
They're essential.
So ambassadors, find them.
Find people who are
intrinsically motivated to help
you with that.
So the special user groups,
continue giving them attention.
They're pretty important
in making this thing work.
[INAUDIBLE] involved, meaning
set up the right channels
to communicate on a frequent
and also on a very visual level.
Communicate on a
very frequent basis.
And last but not
least, it's a change
that is going to
improve lives of people,
and improving the
productivity and the way
of working within your company.
So therefore it's also
momentum to really make sure
that you present it
in a very fun way.
So this is my
presentation so far.
I want to give the
word out to Bas.
BAS ROOKHUIJZEN: Thank
you very much, Ruben.
[APPLAUSE]
So we like to end it up with
answering a few questions
that we've received from you.
Thank you very much.
I saw that this
session was closed now.
So we can sum up a few
questions that have most.
So will the slides be
available afterwards?
If you scroll up, then I think--
that's the number-one question.
We're all about transparency.
RUBEN KRUIT: Of course.
No problem.
BAS ROOKHUIJZEN: What I'll
do is we'll post it somewhere
that you'll be able to find it.
RUBEN KRUIT: Well, maybe
an interesting part
to see on the slides is also--
BAS ROOKHUIJZEN: On the
LinkedIn page, perhaps.
On your LinkedIn page.
RUBEN KRUIT: Oh, whatever.
Yeah, get a lot more,
a lot more connections.
But as see the videos of
the different use cases.
They're very interesting to see.
BAS ROOKHUIJZEN: We'll make sure
it that's easy for you to find,
the slides.
The second one, why
doesn't the G Suite
have the possibility to set
up policies, for instance,
to access management
or password pushes.
Well, it does have that.
If you have the business queue,
for instance, you can set up,
and especially
enterprise queue, you
can set up a vast
majority of settings
where you can push
things like that.
Also in mobile
device management,
for instance, where you
can even distribute data
across certain user groups.
You can copy all the settings
from your Active Directory
settings and what you
have had in the past.
If that doesn't go automatically
for what reason whatsoever,
then we have partners
like Ruben already
mentioned that will
help you set that up.
It's super easy for us to do.
Agree?
RUBEN KRUIT: Fully agree, yeah.
I think the other question
is pretty important.
Why is there so little
promotion for G Suite?
BAS ROOKHUIJZEN:
That's a good one.
We're a well-hidden
secret in that sense.
RUBEN KRUIT: Yeah.
BAS ROOKHUIJZEN: Yeah.
So Google is a
technology company.
We're not that
good in marketing.
You won't see us a lot in
the [INAUDIBLE] dot-blots,
or at the--
so we like to be
relevant and we like
to be found the moment that
you think it's relevant.
So it's in the nature of Google.
We don't make a lot of
advertisement on Google.com
or Androids either.
We just want to have happy users
communicate it to each other.
RUBEN KRUIT: Yeah, well I
can add something to it.
Because OK, it's maybe not
that visual in the promotion.
But on the other hand, once
you are in contact with Google,
they have a very, very
interesting program
for companies to make sure
that you get on their tools,
get on their applications very
smoothly, also by providing
vouchers for the
transition costs,
for instance, or being very
creative in, well let's say,
when your first
license bill is going
to end up on the
[INAUDIBLE] of your company.
So therefore, yeah, I think
that's a different way
of promoting that's getting
people to want your product,
instead of pushing your
product, but making it very easy
for you to do that
transition to that product.
BAS ROOKHUIJZEN: Thank you.
So another interesting
thing is how do you
secure mobile devices in terms
of remote management and policy
provisioning?
So we have two
products for that.
Within G Suite embedded is
mobile device management
already.
So you can enroll all
your mobile devices
that you want, also iPhones.
It doesn't matter.
Android devices, you'll have
way more settings than we
deploy in iPhones in our suite.
But it's still possible.
On top of that, we
have Android for Work.
And that's mobile
application management.
And you can also
push applications,
and the beauty of
it is that other
than the usual mobile
application management suites
that you can buy today,
those are containerized.
Meaning that once
you're in the container,
you can access all the
information, right?
So what we've done we have
tunnels to those applications.
So the applications are just in
between the normal applications
in the phone of the user.
And we have added a
little icon to it.
So it's the icon of a suitcase.
And that enables
you, as a company
to communicate it to the user.
That's very easy to recognize.
Those apps are
company policy pushed.
And those apps I just
download WhatsApp,
whatever the user uses
itself, to himself or herself.
He can just deploy it.
So it's mobile application
management and mobile device
management.
Second advantage is that also
because of this tunneling,
you don't need to
wrap the app anymore.
Third-party apps are
really hard to wrap.
The moment that you want
to put it into a container
that we used that we are
used to working with today,
if you just put them in
the Google App Store,
you create your own Google
App Store for your company.
And then you can push any
app, also all third-party apps
available.
So I hope-- if you have
any specific question,
just contact me.
Then there's a question.
Who are you?
But I put that in there
to check if that's right.
RUBEN KRUIT: All right.
[INAUDIBLE]
BAS ROOKHUIJZEN: We're running
at the end of the presentation.
RUBEN KRUIT: All right.
BAS ROOKHUIJZEN: We were
able, as promised, to answer
the top 3-4 even more question.
RUBEN KRUIT: Yeah, we did.
Yeah, we did.
BAS ROOKHUIJZEN: Thank
you very much, Ruben.
Thank you very much for
coming, and looking forward
to be working with
you in the future.
RUBEN KRUIT: All right.
[APPLAUSE]